[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about
what we want everybody here you guys
know everybody here
yeah i know cat's like a regular now am
i am i considered a regular
welcome back you are welcome as if uh
we you are our distant niece that
always hangs out with us and then our
mom tells us okay take her to the mall
with you and [ __ ] and we're like oh [ __ ]
but it's like all the boys and [ __ ] but
all right you can come and then we
realized like you're actually cool yeah
and then we're like oh hey she's kind of
one of the boys yeah that's cool
that's my whole life yeah except for you
guys are asian oh
a nice i consider you almost like uh i'm
caucasian
yeah he's talking very famously in your
spirit for some reason i sent a little
like mixed asian well thank you not like
full asian but mixed
amazing mm-hmm i think he's asian it's
steve's asian
yeah i feel like his soul the way that
he spends money and looks for deals you
would think he's a chinese grandma
yes and that's beautiful but that's what
you want though that's what you want
is that actually my first time uh doing
an episode with cat
oh [ __ ] this is weird i remember the
last time i was here you were on your
way out and i saw you and the first time
i saw you was like
holy [ __ ] i've watched you growing up
too like i've watched literally
all of you guys like i don't mean to
sound very our little
cousin our little cousin because i'm
from san jose and everyone i grew up
with dances and so like
you were on airlines like tumblr page
when they used to repost tumblr
it was everyone's crush yo he was
everyone's crush wait how old are you
no who's the heartthrob of what of the
group
there's always a heart problem yeah it's
not mike's show no no
hey that answer means anthony he is yeah
he is the heart
he just doesn't want to say it name
someone that wasn't even in the group
yeah
i'm not even a part of the kinjaz yet
i'm the water boy
who's the heartthrob dude in kendra's
there's always a hard thought it's not
mike mike's song
there's there's many different there's
very very many different depends on who
you like though but i think uh i think
for everybody this is a very strong
season for ving
he's very very sexy vietnamese guy
uh i'm attracted to all of them so it's
hard for me to choose
do you have a preference between them uh
there's only like
two that are taller than me but they're
not full time like me so it's hard to
say
back to cat though yeah i say how old
are you
i'm turning 26 this weekend actually oh
baby
that's the hard drive he's sexy dude oh
yeah he's a good looking dude
that's why they don't wear masks that's
why the kids don't wear masks they have
their faces
they're like why would i want to cover
this [ __ ] we actually do wear masks
sometimes i've seen a couple
performances
right yeah that's a cat though maybe not
the best picture of that one
but i can kind of see cat as a kenja
you can see cat as a kindred yeah well i
need any cool asian i kind of see as a
kitchen
are there girls in kendra's there's
girls in the kindred universe they might
not
be like in the crew that like dances in
front of the camera but we have
honestly the women were on our [ __ ] were
you in an asian dance crew i think we'd
be disorganized and survived this long
we didn't have asians
in high school were you in an asian
dance crew women's
no i wasn't i was in an asian dance crew
in college back to cat
yeah back together were you in an asian
dance cruise uh no i danced a little bit
in high school just because that was the
thing that everyone did
and so i used to dance a little bit but
what i
really used to do was just i would go on
youtube
and watch all the guys at that point in
time who are popping off who
everyone who was in like abdc and i
would just watch videos over and over to
try to impress the guys who were
into that yeah because i wanted to date
a dancer
really research on it did you ever think
little cat back then would date a porn
star no i didn't
that's crazy huh oh so you're dating a
porn star now yeah he used to do
uh porn because his ex-girlfriend is a
very famous porn star so they used to do
it together
uh when the pandemic started if you uh
you don't know i know peter
legender yeah very legendary he's great
he was one of my favorites i never look
for the guy
but i feel like guy porn stars are like
djs they pick the good ones
you know they like they like pick good
music you know what's weird so in high
school
uh one of our friends had a like
a prodigy professor friend so he was
maybe like i don't know when i was 15
this guy might have been 25 but he was
already a professor
at a university because he's one of
those guys that graduated college when
he's 17.
nerd and this will he would be like you
guys are amateurs
searching for porn stars by female names
i only search through male names that's
true and i'm like
what oh that's kind of brutal that's
kind of weird dude
he goes trust me the guys are the stars
and they only bang the hottest chicks
and i'm like dude look him up right now
i guarantee he's gay
i was like i don't know i'm like if
you're that focused on the because i
don't even know who the dudes
are you know i'm just brought up here
yeah yeah except for him
but i'm like peter north is legend he's
like the michael jordan you know come on
he really yeah he's the girl dude the
two ghosts oh yeah ron jeremy he's that
was the one i was thinking of yeah
he's the ghost he's a sex offender now
he's in jail he looks like a sex
offender what he looks like a crazy sex
jeremy when you think of
sex offender that's the image that you
have like the hair yeah the build
we saw a homeless guy me and my buddy
saw his homeless guy across the street
and my buddy
swore to god it was ron jeremy but he's
in jail
well yeah he's wrong then he's wrong
jeremy
yeah yeah that guy is three for three
that guy did look like ron jeremy though
you know who's not in jail anymore bill
cosby yeah he just got it
oh yeah yeah and a lot of people are
pissed about that
yeah a lot of people why are they pissed
about it well i he did his time right
no no uh i thought he was for life he
didn't do the time that he was supposed
to do no he wasn't even in jail
like that right i think he was like in
real
real
like sentence are we covering that today
we're probably gonna have to cover it
now we have to okay well yeah
from the uninformed meme that i read
right because i know wrappers
i learned from dj quick okay so dj quick
he got a porn star dj just like a no
regular
the old school rapper yeah dj quick
depends
that would be bad yeah with no c just
the q
u i k quick yeah but um he
posted that he got off because of
technicality
in court like an unfair fair trial
different get off
we're not talking about porn anymore
yeah
so they couldn't charge them of any
crimes because of this stuff
isn't that what people are some people
are pissed because it's like
well you didn't have an actual trial
that's the part that sucks with like the
law
and then even like campaigning there's
so many
rules now that you know everyone's
always trying to win the game
so in law like it's not really about
right or wrong it's like who
it's a game who has the better like game
plan who's the most technical yeah and
even with campaigning
when the two like candidates are going
head to head it's about who has the
better campaign not so much like who's
actually gonna change the country if
anyone ever worked
in that or got in trouble with the law
or like
went through the justice system or got
sued or anything
you'll realize it's not about right or
wrong at all
oh dude it's all about who can win the
game i don't know i didn't hear any of
this on tick-tock news so
that's where i get this more all right
that's where i go where do you follow
tick tock news is there a channel for
that there's a whole bunch of
tick tock news 15 year olds giving you
the best news that's exactly right
yeah that's where i get all my just
kidding news but like tick tock news
that's where all of our viewers went
god damn no but these people are serious
though they really think what they're
saying is the [ __ ] are they actually
smart like us
oh they're smarter they're smarter
because brevity is the solo wit
that's not hard so they're just they're
just nailing everything quick yeah in
and out quick
and they actually like read the articles
and then talk about it yeah we just look
at the memes
yeah we look at the headline and then
and then and then yeah i
stopped reading it and they have an
interpretive dance with it while they're
telling you the news
i was like next level what the [ __ ] am i
doing here we gotta do more details
i keep speaking well we don't even do
news anymore we just like to talk
off the record because if you want the
real news
you get it on patreon phone cause that's
where it's been really cracking
yeah sick improv dude
wow that was good i was following
everything i'm not trained so i don't
even know if it's bad
yeah i'm just like that looks good to me
it's better than sign language to me
i understood it yeah it's just
performance quality back to cat
cat you have the four go
talk about i just wanted to talk about
this theory i have
have any of you guys as men had your toe
stopped before
wait what what exactly oh yeah that's
just bob okay okay here's two here's
crazy
i have a theory that having your toe
sucked
is similar to having your dick sucked
does it feel similar because
no it's not it feels good it would feel
like if i was a guy but what feels even
better
is when you getting it sucked and jacked
off at the same time she's like oh my
god it's too much
get off of me no me and cat were having
this conversation earlier
and she was like i bet joe's got his
toes sucked yeah cause i was actually
getting ready
sometimes i want to watch joe have sex
yeah i absolutely want to watch your
house
a lot of people do joe could be the next
ron jeremy he could be the next peter
north
the next homeless molester perfect
symbol at the bottom of the thing
and said i've never had my toes sucked
but now i feel like i'm missing out
here's the thing i don't want joe to
know that we're watching though because
i think he'll
he'll play to the room i don't want to
perform yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're performing i could i could
be a i could be a performer i could be
i could be method i want you to be
natural you got to put a name cam in his
room
all the time and i've changed my styles
over the years
what's your favorite [ __ ] style bro
so i like to use dance as a reference
because i would say
dance is the physical language of human
beings and
i would say that like when you dance
with a partner
it's not about you it's about us yes
so when i get a hooker right what ends
up happening is uh
i've heard this it depends on the
partner hello everybody today's video is
brought to you by
fields and that's what the f-e-a-l-s if
you don't know what feels is it's a
premium
cbd service and they ship it to your
house when you usually like to take cbd
i actually like to take it on the days
that i filmed
jk news because i'm so amped up with
specifically vietnamese coffee oh it
drives me wild
it's self manufactured stress and
anxiety
if you're a um daredevil and you enjoy
the feelings of anxiety
you feel like you're on top of the world
right yeah but what happens
is i can't go to sleep man yeah
daredevils still have to sleep i tried
everything
jacking off drinking water drinking hot
tea going into the jacuzzi
none of it works i'm tossing and turning
until three in the morning
now field doesn't claim that this is
sleep medicine or anything like that
but i use it in the form of a relaxer
and a balancer
do you like to put in your drink or you
put it like underneath the tongue i like
to put it in a hot tea oh okay
because feels isn't about what you feel
is about what you do not feel man
and all that stress and anxiety it does
help me
unwind when i put take a couple of it
and put it into my
hibiscus tea i sip it i have a whole
ritual i take a hot shower
and it helps me relax in about 30
minutes and i go to sleep before
midnight can you believe that
that's dope so if you guys love
vietnamese coffee like the way we do
or sometimes you're just too hyped too
much anxiety too much adrenaline during
the day and you just want to chill out
and be able to sleep at night
give feels a try it's a premium service
go to
f-e-a-l-s dot com that's fields.com
off the record to get 50 off your first
order
plus free shipping and that's the code
off the record fuels.com
off the record to get 50 off plus free
shipping sometimes your partner is not
capable
of being thrown in the air and back
flipped because of
maybe their height or their size or
their room
you got to see what is the best
methodology
for your partner so what symptoms do you
see really i'm gonna stick my toe in her
mouth a fever
yeah yeah that's what i look for that
wasn't my choice my athlete's foot
take your temperature here you can't ask
someone to suck your toes i think the
person
that was a yeah you just gotta do it
they gotta do it where did you get this
information that getting your toe sucked
to synonymous to getting your
well are you a toe sucker no i'm not a
toe sucker but
um she's a sucky i'm a sucky yeah
[Applause]
you're reading 17 magazine oh yeah
magazine basically told me if i want to
be a bad [ __ ] on tick tock i gotta get
my toast off
that was one of the sex tips that they
give out yeah yeah um
but on only fans people will ask if i
can suck my own toe
and i say no just because like i'm not
comfortable with that and then i'll tell
them i reach it though
yes oh you can that's the only reason
why i'm asking
it's like if it's really the same it's
like i can suck my toe myself but i
can't
i think i can too so you like to have
your toes sucked
uh yes and i thought i need to take yoga
lessons was like
a big joke because i told my boyfriend
about it and he joked about
sucking my toe and i always was weirded
out by that idea
and one day i wasn't paying attention to
him i was ignoring him he did it he put
my foot
in his mouth all five toes oh this it's
like
that tick tock thing where it's like oh
i said it feet as a joke but i don't
think it's a joke anymore like i'm into
getting my toast
all five toes was in his mouth just the
big toe that's hard for pitching this
oh yeah i was just still too shy to ask
him for it so now if i
ignore him i know he's going to put my
foot in his mouth
sen said send this video to him so do
you just consciously ignore
like as you're like baiting him into
mostly every now and then yeah you just
like rub like you put your toes like
around his face like
no i just make sure i don't have socks
on while we're
to be during arguing well or sometimes
i'll pretend like i'm annoyed with him
and then you'll be like oh okay she's
not talking to me how can i get her
attention foot and mouth oh
you guys have excellent communication
skills yeah that is amazing
you know like there's no wondering
because i know he's not going to want to
suck it if there's a sock on it already
so i need them exposed i need them out
yeah that makes a lot of sense i'm going
to see the girls the sock would suck
it's a strategy
you gotta like after taking a shower
you're just like [ __ ]
[ __ ] shining that [ __ ] you'd be like
come over
toe sucking's that good huh i think it's
a lot better than i initially thought it
was
so it just blew my mind when it happened
do you ever go it's not going to suck
itself
no that's the next one that's what you
got to try that's the move do you like
erect the toe to like turn them on
no my toes are pretty hard people do
like uh when your toes are scrunching
like the like the scrunching motion is
really attractive i think bart likes it
the scrunching is attractive i guess
more than the flaring
yes no some people do like the stretch
almost like a webbed look
but most people like the bottom of your
feet the soles because they like seeing
how soft it is
it's not necessarily the front of the
foot that you would think they ain't
gonna
do you guys have a foot fetish you guys
into feet not not really no
not really but like you know it's not
something that i want
yeah same i only know one i was like
that foot person
you remember byron of uh our good old
byron yeah within the group yeah yeah
and he wasn't ashamed
of saying how much he feed drives him
crazy that's time he's like i like
looking at my girlfriend's feet when i
[ __ ] have sex with her
that's awesome right but i always uh
wondered
like what part of that
like the toes or the toenails yeah like
you got you got a lot of feet guys right
so like
what part of your foot makes them go
like
god damn it's usually the souls the
souls of the
let me get into the [ __ ] soul wow i
never got into feet but i really do like
it when
chicks sit on balloons couldn't land it
without laughing is that a thing that
people do oh [ __ ] yeah
it's a whole thing out there man you
know that that would give me anxiety if
i had to sit on balloons and wait for it
to pop i'd be a god like i'd be freaking
out that's how that might be
part of the attraction though yeah just
like a very primal
feeling watching someone's eyes like pop
do we have a balloon here yeah we gotta
get some balloons
all right now do you like toes getting
sucked better than your balls getting
stuck done oh hell nah
balls all the way but what if you had
more nerve endings on your toes you know
i mean if it felt better
i do whatever feels better exactly i for
me i'm just like
you probably did that nasty ass [ __ ] to
somebody else and you [ __ ] threw up
on me
but uh and then i'm like whatever if it
feels great
let's go i was actually propositioned to
get my salad tossed when i was
19 years old by my girlfriend at the
time she was 23
and i was like oh that's disgusting i
would never do that
looking back now i was like you
prolonged
your [ __ ] enjoyment have you shaved
have you looked her up yeah
huh have you looked her up and seen her
with her husband and he's like
i know that in every photo he's like
life is great for me
look he's in the musical he's hyped all
the time all the time
every time i think of toe sucking i
always think of that scene in 40 or
virgin
where she's sucking on his toes yeah and
he freaks out and he kicks her and her
nose is bleeding that's what i think of
so i think i'm a little traumatized by
like the thought of getting my toes up
my [ __ ] has always been
um i'm with very experimental
women that just throw [ __ ] upon me
that's tired i'm just trying it and i'm
like [ __ ] it let's go
dude i have one girl who wanted me to
wear a [ __ ] diaper
what that's what i draw the line did you
do it that's where you drew the line
i was like that's too crazy did she have
it on hand like here put this on
yeah cause her grandparents had depends
on and she thought it was hilarious oh
they were japan
wait was it a joke or was it a kid in
sure can as well she's like can you
drink it
i think the joke turned serious she's
like yeah let me [ __ ] take care of
you like a baby
was she like you need your diaper start
spinning nah this is [ __ ] weird
i like how you you thought about it for
a second i did
i at least considered it i consider
everything maybe in 10 years you'll
revisit it and realize that it was like
getting your i've been prolonging your
pleasure dude joe's a sexual maverick yo
sexual matter dude bro this guy does
and you think this guy only does like
the most crazy [ __ ] but he also does
that in the bedroom too and that's why i
love joe's
cutting edge he's always looking up the
new [ __ ] yeah what's wrong with
the diaper that you're like this is it i
think was it the size of the car i was
on the verge of saying yes but then
the comedy side took over so much to
where the horny side
disappeared i'm fine with it if you're
just sitting there with a rattle but the
second that she tries to [ __ ] me i'm
like wait
you don't treat me like a baby right now
you're not supposed to [ __ ]
yeah in character yeah where's the
continuity no no no
no no no pulls out his pacifier he's
like this is not right this is getting
[ __ ] up now
i'm supposed to just poop and pee and
you you clean me and i need to eat and
i'm gonna cry
you actually met this girl that that
wanted me to be a [ __ ] baby too we
had lunch with her
she was uh she looked like a vietnamese
coffee shop girl
really he's trying to he's thinking feel
free to say her first and last name
do you remember he doesn't remember it
was so long ago but yeah he told me the
name i remember i don't even know her
dave
but we all had lunch together it was
[ __ ] crazy
like post diaper post diaper experience
they're right they're getting something
looking at some bunnies and [ __ ]
yeah weird time getting one of those kid
gates so that you can't go up the stairs
he has to sit in the back seat and she
has to open the door for him and [ __ ]
oh or you're at dinner and you have one
of those like movie scenes where you
slip off your panties that's a diaper
and you hand it to her
with [ __ ] in it or she yeah she's she's
just sitting there and then all of a
sudden
she she sees that you're naked and then
your diapers on the floor full of [ __ ]
you're running around crying do you
think she would have committed to that
no probably oh man if she did i'm
running out of there dude
that is [ __ ] weird yeah well that's
just role play but the second she tries
to [ __ ] you
it's like that's funny this is not role
play yeah this is not role play too much
too much but she goes other way put you
in like a wheelchair gives you like a
cane
you're old yeah it's like a wig on your
head oh man
it tells you to like talk like this old
man
old play old play old that's good
i think i'd rather be a baby than a
grandpa yeah
really i think the other one you feel
like you're trying to like you're you're
almost dead right
well as a baby i feel like i have hope
like i have a whole life ahead of you ah
yeah in the scene i have you know yeah
but then but maybe you didn't like go
through puberty so like what you're
trying to do doesn't like yeah
yeah it's it's kind of weird because
you're like why would you want to do
this to a baby and you're all judging
the girl and [ __ ]
but then when you're a grandpa you're
like oh
i'm like you have but with the walker
and you have to play the [ __ ]
disabled grandpa role too
that comes with that remember remember
we did a jk news episode here about that
one comedian who like wrote this
script one time where he like [ __ ] a
baby or something like that
really here we did it here it was it was
like a famous writer for something
recently
stephen king yeah
and then like an old school thing that
he wrote for a comedy sketch like way
back in the day and
he does this like short video and then
it gets to a baby cr carriage crib or
something like that and then
sound it goes black and there's just
sound effects oh yeah yeah yeah
um seth mcfarland yeah second farm right
that's what i'm saying like i feel like
we did a news episode here and it's like
everybody's like he does a sketch and
it's i guess maybe funny to him at the
time
[ __ ] a baby or something like that
everybody's like that's [ __ ] up but
we're over here talking about like
joe being a baby getting [ __ ] we're
talking about not getting [ __ ] that's
and that's an important difference
yes yes don't [ __ ] baby joe canceled
for that [ __ ]
yeah which is why we're explicitly
saying don't [ __ ] baby joe no
that's why i was like that's where i
drew the line
put a diaper on me for comedy purposes
all day i'll wear a diaper for sexual
purposes
half day i'm running out the door man
what about no diaper but a bib
we could work with that okay because you
know i wear bibs when i go eat crawfish
so this is true it's like less baby
related yep but they don't go
here comes the choo choo when you're
getting crawfish i
would imagine
[Music]